long ago an everlasting being called the
sakuya dragon took root in a Sheena's
lands from it flowed various forms of
immortality powers that would go on to
corrupt the lives of men one of these
was the Dragons heritage a direct line
to the Dragons undying blood and from
that blood came the rejuvenating waters
which was a bewitching force that grants
great resilience to one's flesh
however this power was never meant for
Japan and from these gifts stemmed
infestations and rot leading many like
kudo a divine heir to ponder whether
this power was a blessing or a curse
so atop a sheena castle our goal becomes
to sever this immortality and what
better weapon for this task than the
crimson mortal blade this is one of two
weapons in this world that's capable of
wounding immortal beings and once we
ascend to the dragon's realm with this
sword we can rebuke its power the
crimson mortal blades true name after
all is the gracious gift of Tears and by
making the dragon cry we reject its gift
of everlasting life where is this mortal
blade I've heard it sound in the SEM
port temple the gates to that temple are
closed now though who knows what those
degenerates are doing shut away up there
in the mountains semper temple was once
a place dedicated to Buddhist teachings
these were teachings of selflessness of
death and rebirth however those that the
Sun PO temple have strayed from Buddhist
teachings they have abandoned their
faith
seduced by a search for immortality and
since you're now considered an immortal
being
should you be captured there is no
telling what would become of you you
would do well to return the way you came
despite being these rotting degenerates
infested with immortal centipedes the
monks may not be as evil as they're
being portrayed but we'll get to that
later
the first monks you fight bite down on
sugars to enhance their strength which
should be a strategy that's very
familiar to you if you've been using
these sugars that you find scattered
across all of our China and their
placement around the world is actually
very intentional for in an effort to
curry favor with the Ashe inner temple
monks effectively bribed the ushna with
candy they spread these sugars across
all of these lands in honor of a
Sheena's military heroes gokon and even
our co hunger or Yashiro coup our
statute as we first into Sen Poe these
men once fought for their country but
they all became corrupted turning into
the headless monsters that you find
throughout your travels on go for
example lost his mind in defense of the
state and he was beheaded sinking to the
bottom of the moat and since these sugar
blessings are coming from such tormented
creatures you kind of have to wonder at
what cost to us or them are these
blessings being imparted and you know
while we never really do get a chance to
explore zenpo temples candy factory
the monks themselves use these sugars
really liberally they use every single
one of them except Yasha Riku actually
this candy in particular puts you closer
to death which made it forbidden to the
monks of the temple yet they had no
problem distributing it far and wide in
the name of donations towards their
costly undying research so these sugars
brought them wealth and they brought
them favor with the Ashna and this focus
on wealth in particular actually aligns
with another tool of theirs the golden
vortex it's an upgraded version of
large fan which forces enemies to drop
items and money which are to be
considered donations and it's all ironic
really considering the words of their
founder one should focus only on deeds
of virtue and forego thoughts of
attaining wealth these are the words of
the high priest and they were ideals
that were upheld with the tenacious
mastery of martial arts these martial
arts culminated in the sin PO esoteric
texts a tone that contains skills that
are both martial arts and prayers
weighted strikes that purge the self of
worldly desire for without strength one
cannot defeat the enemies of Buddha and
as we know there's at least one undying
enemy of Buddha occupying a Buddhist
temple in game eventually however this
ideology decayed infested for the sin po
temple was seized by an obsession with
undeath and their martial arts that were
once used for virtue became used in the
pursuit of immortality instead there's
even a curious statue sitting before
their esoteric text that is consumed by
flame it's left half blackened and
burned and if you finish the game you'll
know that this could be a sign of
shrewder a demon that appears in the
bodies of those who have lost all virtue
this is a mural statue and these statues
represented guardians of buddhist law so
it being so badly damaged is wholly
representative of the degradation of sin
pose brand of Buddhism this fall from
grace has a lot to do with symposium
inton with the rejuvenating waters which
as we mentioned earlier is a legendary
source of immortality and it flows from
the dragon's blood we talked about ition
in the last video on the first half of
sekito that you watched and he was a
legendary figure who established a
sheena as the dominant force in the land
we spoke of how he hates the rats from
the interior ministry who are preparing
to invade his land but curiously he also
considers these short assassins to be
rats as they spy on behalf of simple
temple
it seems Asians illness is indeed grave
the land of our China will not last much
longer
even with Genichiro on our side here the
simple assassins spy on Asian ruminating
on how the land of the Hashanah is
doomed
even with Kenichiro on their side tempo
is part of Hashanah after all and its
monks are equally screwed if the
interior ministry invades them all
especially since the interior ministry
actually fears the waters of
rejuvenation and Sampo temple has been
experimenting successfully with the
waters of rejuvenation for years they
have a lot to lose if archana goes down
talking more about these short assassins
they were originally hired to guard
tempo temple but inevitably they became
an extension of the monks will in their
quest for on death their mission became
to kidnap children so that the simpler
monks could experiment on them with the
waters of rejuvenation so circling back
around tuition it's no wonder that he
considers these assassins to be rats and
degenerates in fact knowledge of these
experiments on children could explain
why Asian supports our quest to serve a
kudos immortality and why he's so
disappointed in Ganesha Rose use of the
rejuvenating waters since his grandson
Ganesha wrote actually sided with the
degenerates of sin PO in fact there's
evidence to suggest that Genichiro was
actually encouraging even more research
on the rejuvenating waters through dose
aku who you would have seen
experimenting with them on nationís
behalf in the abandoned dungeon this
place is right outside of simple temple
and dose aku wears a garb that's
actually identical to that of the
bomb-thrower monks in addition he fights
with their martial arts cementing the
connection between the two places and
considering this man was an ex disciple
of Dogon who is another important
character I wouldn't be surprised if
Dogon was also involved with
experiments on the rejuvenating children
as well dotting the hills of Mount Congo
are hundreds of little statues that are
accompanied by red and white pinwheels
these were offered in fond remembrance
for the children that the monks
sacrificed in their experiments with
immortality and at least one of these
children is likely named you might have
heard of him round and round all their
little pinwheels spin and yet the
children are still right here
the spinning spinning red and white
flowers only one pure white flower and
of all the children only one child
survived the ritual it was by a hair's
breadth but mercifully she survived
oh she must have suffered greatly you'd
best treat her kindly this member of the
memorial mob still remembers the event
and it makes sense right because where
you find the departed you will find the
memorial mob there curiously though when
he contracts dragon rot he actually
draws a parallel to what the children
went through during the experiment
children forgive me what's wrong with
you
Buddhas Justin righteous punishment I
had no idea the divine children were
suffering so badly I see now I must make
an offering if he feels guilty but none
should feel more guilt than those who
are directly responsible children of the
rejuvenating water forgive me that child
she's the only one left she must be
lonely trapped in that room by herself
so you're the one who works for the
divine error of the tracking spot that's
right
the divine air is truly exalted but
exulted or not man is still man I'm so
foolish that I didn't understand that
myself don't don't leave your divine air
on his own leave it's too late to regret
what you've already lost them
this man is a high-ranking priest as he
claims to be at fault for the divine
child's confinement furthermore he's
proof that the monks knew that their
experiment was successful but ironically
it also seems like it's impossible for
them to reach the realm where she
resides it's my fault the child she's
confined within the inner sanctum it's
impossible to see her why well this is
just speculation but my theory is that
Buddha himself protects the realm where
the divine child resides because this
space that she's at lies past the
illusory halls this is a realm protected
by the folding screen monkeys beings
that are said to occupy a space between
life and death these guys are a play on
a proverb that you've probably heard see
no evil hear no evil speak no evil
this is a famous proverb of Buddhist
tradition and there's even an invisible
fourth monkey who was a reference to the
do no evil principle then they often
leave out when they're talking about
this legend this to me
is evidence that the Sampo monks turned
a blind eye a deaf ear a mute voice upon
their sinful path to enlightenment and
it's likely to me that this bossfight
represents that fact
there exists a prosthetic in secular
called the large fan which allows you to
spirit people away all of the monks of
simple temple were actually spirited
away once before that's why they're here
but if you spirit them away again
rumors say they'll disappear forever
unless of course they're Kotaro a kind
semper monk or unless they're the other
monk here in the illusionary halls who
seems legitimately set on achieving
nirvana the fact that these two
wholesome legitimate monks are the only
beings that were actually able to reach
these halls when they're spirited away
twice plays into my belief that Buddha
is perhaps protecting this realm from
the infested by the way there was once
someone who like you was on a mission I
believe he chased the monkeys for a
while but everything here eventually
went silent this someone is almost
certainly
Genichiro he's a man with friendly links
to semper temple a man who is looking
for the mortal blade and he's someone
who would have found it impossible to
catch the monkeys since he doesn't have
the same talents that we have it's
almost as if this was meant to be solved
by us
please forgive them they only sought to
keep me hidden
[Music]
however it seems it was not meant to be
[Music]
close your eyes
let us meet at the inner sanctum
here the divine child of the
rejuvenating waters parts you finally
with the mortal blade which you're able
to draw
thanks to your resurrected powers I
accepted power wolf that sword on your
back is it the sword that can kill those
who cannot die yes it was given to me by
the divine child of the rejuvenating
waters at simple temple the divine child
of the rejuvenating waters the monks at
simple temple abandoned the ways of
their faith in pursuit of immortality
the result is those who have false
dragon's heritage known as the divine
children of the rejuvenating waters a
false dragon's heritage I never would
have thought wait divine children yes
many were created but only one survived
further proof of the corruption this
power brings to man the ties of
immortality must be severed yes my lord
now that you have the gracious gift of
Tears we can actually acquire the
Dragons tears and sever immortality
interestingly though we are not the
first to seek the Crimson mortal blade
with immortal severance in mind many
years ago there was a woman named Timon
and a divine heir names Takeru who tried
to do the same Tim OS note reads
returning to the divine realm is
hopeless and I wish only to sever the
dragon's heritage and restore his
humanity what she's describing is the
purification ending where the earthbound
commit sudoku restoring the divine airs
mortality and the humanity she goes on
to write restoration requires the ever
blossom and the mortal blade and yet I
cannot acquire the latter the mortal
blade was hidden by the high priest of
sin po temple who has no desire to sever
the immortal ties the high priest is
central to everything in SEM PO he was
the founder of this town
so we need to figure out what his
motivations were for creating the divine
child for starting this temple for
hiding away the mortal blade and for
creating the divine children we find him
dressed all in blue his corpse
sequestered away in a cave and instead
of immortal severance which term away
wanted the high priest wanted a
different ending turns out he was
actually gunning for the Dragons return
ending which he must have looked up on a
wiki or something because that shit's
complicated but to this end and for this
dragons return ending he outlined his
journey in two sacred scriptures the
first text that describes his journey is
wholly chapter infested depending on
when you arrive here
it's either in the hands of the
regretful monk outside the halls of
illusion or it's thrown to the bottom of
the lake in disgust it lays out a
founding principle for SEM po temple
that their journey is to spend an
eternity musing on why they cannot die
the text is from the perspective of the
high priest and it reads for an age I
have been blessed by the worm to be
undying is to walk the eternal path to
enlightenment
thus I must become enlightened to
understand why I cannot die it is said
that the holy dragon's origins were in
the West so I wonder how did the worm
come to be bestowed upon me this text
reveals potentially major twist in
simple temples law it reveals that their
founding principle isn't necessarily to
acquire immortality
after all the monks already assumed they
were immortal from the centipedes No
instead their founding goal was to
understand their infestation something
the high priest considered enlightenment
although whether it is enlightenment and
whether the path to that enlightenment
was justified that is another story but
he believed that the Avenue to this
enlightenment was the creation of a
divine child of the rejuvenating waters
and they abandoned all virtue and ethics
while chasing that creation and when you
give the divine child this text it
explains to her why she was created I
was told to give this to you thank you I
will accept it what's wrong I I still
cannot help but detest them in the end
though the information within does set
her on a path to the dragon's return
there is something I would like to
discuss I believe we should aim not to
sever the dragon's heritage but instead
to return it to its rightful place
return the dragon's blood that's right
the dragon's heritage was set free from
its homeland and it drifted here to
Japan its power was never meant for this
land until something is done it will
continue to corrupt the lives of those
who encounter it the dragon's heritage
and those connected to it it is only
right that they return home to the west
to the birthplace of the divine dragon
however there is one problem I am unsure
of the exact destination who would know
perhaps the high priest of sin po temple
and here's he's the founder of sin po
temple I wonder how old he actually is
he has secluded himself in a five-story
pagoda past the narrow cave not far from
here shinobi of the Divine air yes this
path differs from that of the one to
sever immortality I do not wish to force
my opinion upon you should you wish to
return the dragon's heritage then /
you should seek out the high sanpo
priest the infested chapter speaks of
his undying journey towards
understanding why he cannot die and the
second chapter
dragons return lays out his conclusions
it reads undying I pray the Dragons
return undying love let us wait an age
for the divine heir to assimilate the
cold dragon tears the cradle to consume
the pair of serpentine fruits let the
cradle enjoy giving him shelter granting
his return to the west
the serpentine fruits mentioned are the
dried and fresh hearts of the Serpent's
of the sunken Valley and SEM PO actually
has a lot of pre-existing links with the
snakes and with the valley that are
really easy to miss however discussions
surrounding the snakes will continue in
the sunken Valley episode and will go
deeper into the Dragons return I think
in the endings video remember to
subscribe and bring the notification
bell so you don't miss out by the way
it's coming soon I want to leave you on
a really important topic the infested
the centipedes you probably thought I'd
mentioned them earlier
they're so core to simpl temple and yet
I mentioned them last because just like
the monks and their motivation we don't
really have enough information on them
yet in my opinion to draw guaranteed
conclusions what we do know is that the
centipedes are found within hanbei the
semper monks the guardian ape and the
corrupted monk and in all of these
examples the hosts actually have a
pretty symbiotic relationship with the
centipede they're able to carry on their
goals while infested whether it be
defending a bridge meditating on undeath
or just cultivating a flower to give to
a mate the centipede is more than happy
to stay in the body for a ridiculous
amount of time and that might be their
goal we'll get to that later but
assuming that the rejuvenating waters
and the fountainhead waters are the same
thing then these waters are actually
what all the infested have in common the
guardian ape resides in a valley where
the fountain headwaters pool deeply the
corrupted monk guards the fountainhead
palace
and could also have linked the sin /
monks who themselves have studied the
waters for an age to me it makes a lot
of sense that the centipedes come from
these waters after all the waters stem
from the Dragons heritage and the
Dragons heritage too has its own form of
stagnation in the form of dragon rot
which eats away at one's lifeforce the
centipedes mirror that stagnation in the
waters of rejuvenation sealing it for me
is that there is actually one more place
that the centipedes appear it's very
hard to find but deep below Fountainhead
lake surrounding the corpse of a giant
carp are tens of luminescent centipedes
which might mean that they infest the
very source of the rejuvenating waters
interestingly giant carp in sekito
are supposedly everlasting and have
goals of becoming a dragon and the fact
that some centipedes have stripped away
and immortal corpse is curious to say
the least in addition there are multiple
Japanese legends that link centipedes
and Dragons but those are tales for
another time for all their mentions
about centipedes making the infested
immortal they might actually not fall in
the cave by the five-tier pagoda
we find the high priest and his peers as
still and as dead as the centipedes that
rest upon them the nature of the high
priest son death is by far the most
intriguing part of sin po temple did he
know when he was going to die is this
why he and his peers hid away in a cave
so no one would find out did the
centipede leave their bodies once it was
fully grown does it have some objective
beyond this place where did it go and
also how did this guy discover so much
about the Dragons return and what was
his relationship like with the divine
child she knows about him somehow after
all there's a lot of questions that I
could speculate on for hours but this
has gone too long already I'm curious
though as always what do you think I've
actually decided to split the majority
of sekito story into four parts now and
I'm doing this for a few reasons
because it allows me to go into way more
detail as you can probably tell from
this episode and partly because hey I
get to Commission a bunch of incredible
art for every single episode so that
makes me happy
if you want to access all my notes or if
you want full-sized exclusive wallpapers
that you see featured on these
thumbnails then check out our patreon or
just subscribe with twitch prime over on
Twitch the next few weeks are all about
the law so stay tuned and I'll hash all
over now
[Music]